hello everyone while we're enjoying the
snooze fest in London as today is the
rest day I thought it would be a very
nice idea to check up on a very nice
blitz game as so many of you have
suggested it we have to go some 8,000
kilometers all the way from London to
Kolkata as there the Tata Steel chess in
the ablates tournament 2018 is being
held and we have a game between
rameshwar Bracknell and up and the
Vishwanathan Anand and it is their first
ever encounter over the board so I
decided to name the video first contact
you know maybe maybe kind of draw a
parallel there between Star Trek's first
contact because here pragna nonde
improved so much and he has made so much
progress that he is now contacted by
much stronger grandmasters and
organizers to play in these events so
here it's gonna be a really really an
exciting game and I'm sure Anand really
also feels the pressure as he wants to
leave as good as impression as possible
he knows that he is a role model to
every young grandmaster and
international master in India who wants
to make an effort for for himself so
definitely he's going to take this game
very seriously and he does with which
you will see before we check out the
actual game I just do have one very
exciting
well drawing to share with you a
subscriber sent me this and this was
drawn by his six-year-old daughter now
it doesn't seem like much unless you
know what's happening here these two
goats and they are in fact the goats I
have confirmation there are goats are
actually Magnus crossing and Fabiana
karana on the left you can see it
actually says magnus carlsen but you
have to read it from bottom to top so
there we have it magnus carlsen and in
the in the little cloud in there it says
in the bubble it says even but what it
what it actually means is I win and the
other guy is
karana and he says oh no so did the
little girl the six-year-old girl
predicts the outcome
of the 2018 World Championship only time
will tell but you know it really
children are fascinating how does she
see Carlton Caruana as to goats is
beyond me but still a very impressive
drawing so I do hope you enjoyed that
now let's check out this very nice game
partner nanda opens with E 4 and we have
C 5 by Anand
so already you can see that Anand is
very interesting interested in a fight
and being one of the greatest Sicilian
players of of today yeah pregnant of
course knows that and surely he came
very prepared Knight to f3 d6 d4 C
captors on d4 let me just fix that
Knight captures on d4 Knight to f6
Knight to c3 and a6 we of course have
the knight or variation on the board and
well what could be more exciting than an
ID or Sicilian and here a3 a move that
became popular only recently also I've
seen h3 being played in this game and
none of the older lines are really very
much popular with white now but it's
actually a very useful move i I I do
play now but before it always seemed
like a huge waste of a tempo but if you
think about it black will always want to
develop his pieces especially with the
b5 Bishop to b7 and at some point he
will want to put b4 so playing a three
you know does make sense and I remember
a lot of games were I was constantly
calculating what if I pushed g5 and he
pushes before I do this he does that I
do this he does that and you know always
spent a lot of time on this so a three
right off the start and let's see what
happens next
on the decides to play g6 we have Bishop
to e2 and Bishop to g7 VN carrying the
bishop also I don't want to forget it by
the end of the video in the description
below the first thing you will see is a
link that this exact game on Chazz based
in Diaz channel where you can watch the
actual footage of the game it's really
exciting so do check it out
best of three three we have castles
Queen to d2 now pregnant under has the
Queen Russia battery at some point you
want to exchange the dark square bishop
by playing Bishop to h6 we have b5 by
Anand
continuing with the usual night of stuff
queenside castle and now Bishop to b7
and now has a double attack against the
e4 pawn with the knight and the bishop
here so pregnant that defends it with f3
and now having this very nice central
structure he will want to start pushing
h4 n the g4 as that's what you want to
do when Black has a fee in Cairo the
bishop ended this structure on the Kings
side we have Knight bt7 by Anand this
Knight canal either come into the game
via b6 e5e5e5 a depending on what by a
white place we have h4 of course you
want to attack on the King side and we
have the Knight to e5 we have Bush up to
h6 pregnant on the wants to exchange
dark square bishop s-- we have Bishop
captures Queen captures and here up to
c8 and here it's a very there's a lot of
tension here you have to calculate a lot
of things of course
Anand will have to calculate what
happens if h5 is played and it's very
interesting here prague who played the
g4 and he gave up a crucial tempo to
Anand
after this g4 on and played rook
captures on c3 and then the entire game
became something that well resembles a
blitz game of course but it's very
interesting
h5 is the better idea here than the g4
pregnant on the plate and it's very
interesting if you like ask me the SAP
Ragnar and I have all the variations up
until move 14 about the knight of the
Cellini and I said I would most likely
say yeah I'm sure he does I mean he's
such a young Grandmaster surely he has
all of it in his head but it seems that
you know just being such such wonderful
thing it is impossible to have
everything and it's not all that easy to
see why
h5 is much better well of course if you
play G captures on h5 will you don't
want to play this you give up the f5
squared then right Knight f5 is winning
Queen g7 the threat of checkmate now
after you
block it now real characters on h5 ah
there is no defense against both Queen
captures on h7n even if you prevent this
then Queen g7 will again be checkmate
but even without ruining your pawn
structure you could capture with the
night for example Knight captures on h5i
but again rook captures on h5 and after
you capture again knife to a5 and again
there is no way to defend the g7 square
Queen to g7 will be checkmate
so h5 a very dangerous move and if Anand
would play rope captures on c3 now then
he he doesn't really have time for this
because if h5 was playing instead of g4
didn't get H captures on g6
H captures F captors and g6 you don't
want to if you don't want to allow DF v
square for whites night so you do have
to block it and you cannot capture with
the H pawn because going to h8 will be
checkmate
so here but now when I see six wins you
don't need a DF v square anymore as
there is the threat of checkmate and if
you block it you will lose the Queen on
c8 so a lot of very cool ideas here and
lastly but of course not leastly after
h5 Queen to a5 also getting the Queen
out of the way so ideas with 96 will not
be possible again f4 will be extremely
good for what for white now after real
captures on c3 you will play G captures
hCAP source on g6 of course and after
pawn captures now you will capture on e5
and now we enter this very nice
variation of rook captures on a3 where
black would be threatening checkmate as
the Queen is controlling the d2 square
you would have to capture it but after
Queen captures King moves Queen before
checked Knight will block would be 3
then comes D captures on e5 but still
white will be white will be much better
here he is up a whole rook and even
though black does have some counter play
with King b2 and the rook to e1 white
should have no problems winning this so
very interesting I thought it'd be a
good idea to just to show it as I mean
it's a position that can very well
happen in a lot of your games where you
have to decide whether you want to
prepare h5o you just want to push it
immediately and if you if you see that
you might have a lot of use for this a
f5 square or even the e6 square perhaps
you will find the h5 move in your own
games because it's different because the
exchange happened I mean of course if
you have a queen d2 and Bishop e3
battery you will always play Bishop to
h6 that's normal but most of the times
it's actually white who will capture on
g7 with the bishop and King captures
it's a very rare that black will apps
actually captured a bishop on h6 and a
lot of Queen captures on h6 which is
what Anand played here so bit different
but that that is why h5 is possible here
but okay g4 was played by problem and
now rook captures on c3 and now captures
it now there is nothing to capture on
the Kings side as g4 was of course
slower than h5 be captors on c3 and now
Queen to a5 and then know that this is a
blitz game so of course no one will find
all of the lines do over the board we
have Queen to a5 and now Prague who
doesn't even bother playing Kings to b2
to defend his pawns as he run would gain
a lot of momentum look to see a to go
after the c3 pawn and then progress
attack is over he has to bring the Queen
back and even though this might be
better
Bravo decides to give us a very exciting
game in he decides to go all out so
after an ins Queen to a5 probables
Knight to f5 already Prager is
threatening Queen g7 checkmate of course
you have to capture the knight G
captures on f5g captures on i-5 now
opening up the G file and now comes
Queen captures on c3 here there is uh
there is an even stronger move but I
mean it's it's really an engine move and
to find such a movie in a blitz game
would be would not be possible I'd say
but you could play something like rook
eg for a knight eg for story yeah give
back the piece and now you will either
have a very strong night on on g4 on the
other hand if you captured it then you
get Knight captures on e4 the G file is
closed you're still controlling the D 2
square Queen captures on a3 is coming
and it will be it will be a very
wrong game for black now if if not
winning but okay after G captures on a
five islands idea is very much similar
he first plays Queen captures on c3 and
now comes Rudy to g1 now Anand decided
to close the G file the other way he he
decides to give up the extra piece by
playing Knight to g6 we have pawn
captures here and thought about does he
capture with the HP nor does he capture
with the F pawn he decided to go with
the F pawn and here we have h5 and this
is the moment where Prague will simply
allows Anand too much the problem is and
I was a I was when I was watching this
game I just base India channel I was
always considering this Knight captures
on e4 move and I knew that there is a
problem with the e4 pawn so I didn't
know what the correct move here is most
likely h5 is what I would play as well
but Bishop to d3 you have to reinforce
this efore pawn and not allow any
captures towards the pawn but okay we
have h v here and here very
interestingly I thought that Knight
captures on e4 wins for black because
now the D 2 square is covered and Queen
2 a1 the threat of checkmate will be
overwhelming because now after pawn
captures Bishop captures there's really
no good way to prevent Queen captures
and c2 checkmate
and also the bishop from here guards the
g6 square so no-look g6 ideas are
possible here and of course if you try
to defend it with Queen d2 then you take
away the d2 square from White's King
Queen a1 will be checkmate and then I
was really surprised when instead of
Knight captures on e4 and actually
played Bishop captures on e4 but okay
then I realized that after Knight
captures on e4 you don't have to capture
it rather instead of capturing you can
just give up the rope rook captures on
g6 and now after pawn captures Queen
captures with Czech Queen half the Queen
has to block otherwise you have a
otherwise you have a checkmate if you go
King to h8 then Queen to h6 and you will
get checkmated here after Queen to g6
checkmate
but after this Knight captures rook
captures on g6
well we have talked after squink after
so now Queen to g7 now you would get
simply pawn captures any for Queen
captures pawn captures and now after
virtue captures on e4 most likely rook
to h7 attacking the e7 pawn and after E
5 black would still be better but it's
hard to say if this is actually winning
most likely it's not so that's why Annan
finds the the absolute best move after
h5 not the one I thought that was good
the knight captors only four but Bishop
captures on e4
now comes F dr. Sonny for Prague has to
do this because Anand saw that after you
defend checkmate because there is a
threat of checkmate here brush up to d1
wood could be played to defend it but
now you have a lot of other problems
Queen captures on a three-track King
moves and now comes the Bishop captures
on f3 simply attacking that rook on h1
and also the Bishop on d1 so after bunch
of characters Queen captures there are
no tricks anymore Woodrow capture son
beat on g6 so H captures now comes
Knight to e4 check and now white is
getting check made it after a very nice
King walk King c1 queen a3 check if you
go King b1 you get nice to see 3
checkmate and if you try to go to the
other way as the dt squared is covered
by the night king d1 then you get Queen
e1 check King moves and now rook to have
to check the knight from me for is of
course protecting the rook King the 3
Queen c3 check you give up the night
King captures and now after Queen f3
check King before E 5 will be checkmate
as the pawn and the Queen are covering
all of the lights worse here and the
Queen is of course cutting of the the
entire 3rd rank here as you can see so
after Bishop captures on e fourth the
very nice move on and found Praga
decided to capture it so we have sorry
about that after Bishop captures on e4
probably decided to capture it f cap F
captures on e4 and now comes Queen to a1
check not even preparing it with Knight
captures only for preparing checkmate
because now white would actually win
after rook captures on g6 you would
again face this
exact same checkmate Queen h6 King g8
what would you want check and Queen to
g6 will be checkmate
so after this F captures an e-form Queen
to a1 check immediately by Anand we have
King to d2 and only now Knight captures
on e4 Queen to eat King to e3 and now
you are honored here continue this King
hunt feel free to pause the video here
and try to figure out how to continue
this attack I will give you a couple of
seconds as usual for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent King Hunter and for
those of you who just wanna enjoy show
Queen the c3 check you give up the
knight on e4 and the problem is with
capturing the night which was not played
in the game that's now d five wins in
captures and now the rook can also join
the King hunt King goes back now comes
Luke to d4 check king e5 now you always
know when the King starts coming up the
board that it's all over
Queen c5 check King moves and Queen to
d6 will be checkmate
so after Queen to c3 check Bishop to d3
was played by Prabhu but now you face a
lot of other problems now you can see
the relationship between the black Queen
and the White Queen so on and single
played Queen to d2 check
now the knight has to be captured to
King captures and now comes Queen
captures on h6 and but oh okay although
white lost the Queen
it's a blitz game it's still very much
possible but progress was very very long
time here he only had a few seconds on
the clock and he fought valiantly here
and he even created some chances which
you will see H captors and g6 now the
black queen is attacked we have Queen to
f4 check first getting out of the way
King to d5 and now h6 closing up the
file and the Queen is guarding the h6
pawn g7 attacking the rook we have
grouped the CH taking away the C file
from White's King King to be 6 and now
d5 preparing Queen to d6 check but Praga
doesn't allow it
we have looked to g6 rook the c6 check
we have King captures on e7 and here
rook captures on g6 here
Prager was I think he probably was down
to 3 seconds here and under
mrs. Queen to f7 check after a king to
d8 rook to c7 will threaten both of
these checkmates but there's no reason
to find it as progress so much a very
long time but also it could have gone
differently you know it could have been
really dangerous as even with a few only
a few seconds on the clock
Prague was still managed to create one
very nice trap rook captures and g6 was
played by Anand Bishop capture son g16
capture son g7 and now Bishop back to d3
so still you have a protected bishop on
d3 and the rook can the rook can create
some problems
Queen e5 check King d7 and now h5
starting to push the past pawn also the
opponent h5 is not protected by the
black Queen rook g1 check King f6 rogue
g6 check King f7 rock to h6 and now a5
we have King to c6 now before we have
captures captures and now King back to
d7 by Prague Oh King to g7 attacking the
rook we have rook to e6 attacking black
Queen Queen the Queen d4 and here we
have King to yet and here again Prague
was constantly playing with his
increment again he was I think it was
around 3 or 5 seconds here but like I
said you do have a video containing the
actual footage of the game so do check
it out but here if Anand just continued
for example pushing his passed pawn then
it would have been enough to draw the
game because here probably prepared rook
g6 check and now if you go looking h7
rook the g4 check opens up a check from
the bishop and also wins the Queen here
so you would even either have to move
the King and all our capture screen or
give up the Queen for the bishop a for
the pawn and now this would be even
worse as white would be even winning now
and on the other hand of course you will
not if you already wonder like this you
will not go king gage soon but King h8
and then of course you have to allow a
perpetual here and I draw by repetition
so after King yet Queen g4 was played
now although you can capture the Queen
here if you play something like this but
again you're up three points and it's an
easily winning endgame so after a queen
2g4 prague tried king to e7 but now
comes h4 I will have Bishop to e2 Queen
g5 check King d6 and now h3 rope to e7
check King to f8 we have rook to e5
attacking the Queen and now rook a Queen
to f6 check we have King captures on d5
and now after h2 pregnant and this I
decided to resign the game as there is
nothing more he can do here at some
point black can even capture here on e5
and after King captures promote into a
queen you cannot prevent the pond from
queening Bishop to f3 the Queen will
simply capture it so nothing more to be
done here if something like rook h5 to
protect the pond then Queen f7 check
King moves and even Queen captures after
Beryl captures again you will get a
queen into the game and again a very
nice winning game for Anand so King
capture Sun d5 h - i was in this
position that pregnant under resigned
the game and this their the first
encounter of these two great
grandmasters ended by Anand winning the
game so I'm sure I'm sure
pregnant is very happy with his game but
I'm sure he really really wanted to win
this one so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I think it's kind of
a refreshing you know to see a nice
blitz game even though it's a blitz game
but maybe with the maybe with the dry
games in the World Chess Championship we
are facing you know it's it's it's nice
to check up on a game like this I would
like to thank Thomas Keating Vladimir
Horowitz Jonathan Blake's Anton camisa
and field Milkovich for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos see our think all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content and if by any chance you have
more interesting drawings such as these
two goats which represent champion and
Challenger
you know also do share so we can share
it with everyone thank you all and I
will
soon